que se passe-t-il juste après la mort
sortez de vous même et juste avant la
vraie mort si elle devait avoir lieu
vous êtes ailleurs de plus en plus de
personnes réanimé après un arrêt
cardiaque raconte avoir vécu une
expérience intrigue août
je suis rentré dans la lumière et
c'était peut-être une lumière d'amour
une substance d'amour c'est une
expérience de mort imminente
appelé aussi eu et demi ma monna vie
j'étais mort d'un je partais c'était
beau c'était merveilleux
alors j'ai pas peur de mourir je le dise
à tout le monde si c'est ça de partir
c'est merveilleux l'étude de ce
phénomène est né aux états unis dans les
années 70 avec le psychiatre raymond
nous dit grâce aux milliers de
témoignages recueillis il établit la
première grille des différents stades
observé par les patients la sortie du
corps
le passage dans le tunnel l'arrivée dans
la lumière et cette revue de vie mais on
trouve des corrélations fortes qui font
de ces étapes des constantes qui
reviennent très régulièrement en france
la communauté scientifique commence à
s'intéresser à ces expériences dans les
années 80 la première thèse sur ce sujet
et publié en 1983 par deux médecins
grenoblois elisabeth et ses rites
schnetzler et frédéric sont ils sont
alors les premiers à écouter la parole
des patients sans jugement moment on a
fait cette thèse
c'est quelque chose qui est absolument
pas reconnu on s'est déjà fait cette
expérience on pensait qu'il délirait ok
raconter des histoires mais il faudra
attendre 1991 pour qu'une étude
similaire à celle de mutti soient menées
en france auprès de victimes d'arrêt
cardiaque
va j'ai interrogé car il convient entre
elles avaient vécu cela neuf personnes
neuf personnes ont raconté quelque chose
qui s'est beaucoup qui fait ce qui fait
beaucoup dans la mesure où la mesure où
on n'a pas fait de sélection sur le sur
le contenu de ce qui nous a été racontée
depuis 2009
sam pas renié un médecin britannique en
soin intensif a mis en place une vaste
étude scientifique 2000 personnes ayant
subi un arrêt cardiaque y participeront
en octobre 2014
il présente ses conclusions le cerveau
aurait bien une activité après la mort
le cerveau pourrait peut-être continuer
à fonctionner combien de temps jusqu'à
trois minutes disent les auteurs de
l'étude
c'est la première fois que le témoignage
d'une personne ayant vécu une expérience
de mort imminente et corroborés dans le
cadre d'un dispositif scientifique
[Musique]